Everything we've done with
polynomials so far has been
either adding or multiplying
them.
But what if we wanted
to go the other way?
What if we actually wanted
to factor a polynomial?
Let me show you what I mean.
So let's have the polynomial
3x to the
third power minus 21x.
When I say factor it, I
essentially want to break it
up into the product of, maybe
polynomials, it could be a
mononomial, which is
just one term.
And to do that over here, we
could factor out a 3x here.
So if you factor out a 3x this
is equal to 3x times-- what's
3x to the third divided by 3x?
Let me write this
way actually.
This is the same thing as 3x
times 1/3 x times 3x to the
third minus 21x.
Notice, 3x times 1/3x, I'm
not changing the number.
This is 3x/3x, this is 1.
But the reason why I picked 3x
is because I saw that both of
these terms are divisible
by 3x.
And you're going to see
that when I divide
both of them by 3x.
So this is going to be the same
thing as 3x times 3x to
the third over 3x
minus 21x/3x.
And now this is going
to be equal to 3x.
What's this first
term equal to?
The 3's cancel out.
x to the third divided by x.
We learned in our exponent
rules, you could just subtract
the exponents there.
That's x times x times x divided
by x, just going to be
x times x, or just x squared.
So it's going to be, this first
term here is just going
to be an x squared.
And then the x's cancel
out here.
21 divided by 3 is 7.
x squared minus 7.
And if you multiply them out,
you're going to see you're
going to get 3x to the
third minus 21x.
Now I went through all of these
steps really, just to
show you exactly
what I'm doing.
But as we progress, you're going
to see that your brain
will just automatically say,
hey, both of these are
divisible by 3x, let me factor
out a 3x, and then divide both
of these terms by 3x to
get x squared minus 7.
Let's do another one.
Let's say we had 4x to
the third plus 10x
squared minus 2x.
So when I look at this,
immediately what pops out is
that all of these terms are
divisible by 2, and all of
them are divisible by x.
So let me factor out a 2x.
So this is equal to 2x times--
and when we factor out a 2x
let's divide each of
these terms by 2x.
4x third divided by 2x.
4 divided by 2 is 2.
And then x third divided
by x is x squared.
And then we have plus 10x
squared divided by 2x.
10 divided by 2 is 5.
x squared divided by x is x.
And then finally, negative
2x divided by 2x is
just negative 1.
And you know, if you don't
believe me, just
multiply this out.
Distribute the 2x and you
will get exactly this.
So all we see, we try to look
for something that's divisible
into every term.
We factor it out, factoring it
out, we put it outside of a
parentheses, so to speak.
And then we divide each of those
terms by that factor.
We did that explicitly
up here.
Now you're probably saying,
hey Sal, why are we even
worried about doing this?
And the answer is, is it really
helps us solve a lot of
certain types of polynomial
equations.
Let me show you what I mean.
Let's say we have the polynomial
equation 9x squared
is equal to 27x.
And we want to make sure that
we get all of the x's that
satisfy this equation.
So let me subtract 27x
from both sides.
So I get something
that equals 0.
And this will be a general trend
whenever you're doing
polynomial equations, very
oftentimes you will.
The left-hand side becomes
9x squared minus 27x.
The right-hand side becomes 0.
And now over here, we can see
that both of these terms are
divisible by 9x, right?
27 is divisible by 9, so is 9.
And they're both
divisible by x.
So let's factor out a 9x.
So 9x squared divided
by 9x is just an x.
And then 27x divided by 9x.
That's negative 27/9
is negative 3.
And then the x divided
by x is just a 1.
So this is 9x times x minus 3--
you can multiply it out to
verify that these are the
same thing-- is going
to be equal to 0.
Now this part is interesting.
When I take the product of two
numbers, and I say they're
equal 0-- let me do a
little aside here.
If I were tell you that a times
b is equal to 0, what
does that tell us?
That tells us that either
a or b or both are 0.
At least one of these
two have to be 0.
Maybe both of them are going
to be equal to 0.
So we're doing the exact
same thing here.
We're taking the product-- you
can view that as a, you could
view that as b-- we're taking
the product of two numbers and
saying that that product
is equal to 0.
So that tells us that either 9x
is going to be equal to 0,
or x minus 3 is going
to be equal to 0.
Either of these, or both of
these, are going to equal 0.
This we know how to solve.
Divide both sides by 9.
You get x is equal to 0.
This we know how to solve.
Add 3 to both sides.
And you're left with x-- because
these cancel out-- is
equal to 3.
So this equation here actually
had two solutions. x could be
0, and you can verify that.
0 is equal to 0.
Or x could be equal to 3.
9 times 9 is the same
thing as 27 times 3.
And you might have been able
to figure that out in your
head, but when you do it this
way you make sure that you get
all of the solutions
to the problem.
Let's do one more like this.
Let's say I had 4a squared
plus a is equal to 0.
Once again, we can
factor an a out.
Both of these terms are
divisible by a, so this is the
same thing as a times
4a plus 1, right?
When I factor an a out, I took
the a out of the parentheses,
and then I divide each
of these terms by a.
And that's going to
be equal to 0.
So that means either a is equal
to 0, or 4a plus 1 is
equal to 0.
Well, that's one solution
right from the get go.
And this one right
here, we could
subtract 1 from both sides.
We get 4a is equal
to negative 1.
And then you could divide
both sides by 4.
And we get a is equal
to negative 1/4.
Now I said that was the last
one, let me do one more.
Because I want to show you,
here, I'm factoring and then
solving, but I want to show
you how useful a factored
polynomial is.
So I'm going to start with one
that's already factored.
So say I had x minus 5 times 2x
plus 7 times 3x minus 4, is
equal to 0.
And if you're bored, you can
actually multiply these out
and you'll find that you get
a third degree polynomial.
But if you want to solve
that being equal to 0,
it'd be very difficult.
But this, we're going to
see, is not too bad.
As we said, if we have three
numbers, if we have a times b
times c equal to 0, that means
that at least one of these are
0, maybe more than one.
Either a or b or c, or some
combination of them,
are equal to 0.
So once again, I have
three numbers.
This could be viewed as an a.
This could be viewed as a b.
This could be viewed as a c.
I'm multiplying them and
they're equal to 0.
So that means that either
x minus 5 is equal to 0.
Or 2x plus 7 is equal to 0.
Or 3x minus 4 is equal to 0.
And we can solve each of
these independently.
Add 5 to both sides of this
equation, and you get x is
equal to 5.
So that's one solution
to this equation.
Over here, subtract
7 from both sides.
You get 2x is equal
to negative 7.
Divide both sides by 2.
You get x is equal to
negative 7 over 2.
That's another solution.
And then finally, add 4 to both
sides of this equation.
You get 3x is equal to 4.
Divide both sides by 3.
You get x is equal to 4/3.
So this third degree polynomial,
if you were to
multiply it out, actually had
three solutions to that
polynomial equalling 0.
And we're going to see, these
are actually called roots of
the polynomial, the x values
that make that polynomial
equal to 0.
But hopefully, you've just
gotten an appreciation for
one, how to factor a polynomial
in this video, and
also, why it's useful for
solving polynomial equations.